[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Freitag die vom Sport hat Norbert
Lehmann schönen guten Abend schauen wir
auf die Themen von heute
Raketen auf die Ukraine wieder sterben
Zivilisten bei Luftangriffen das Land
macht sich bereit für eine
Gegenoffensive
Zukunft der Energieversorgung eine
Anlage in Schwerin zeigt wie Erdwärme
für mehr klimafreundliche Energie sorgen
kann
und Wölfe im Visier Landwirte wollen
problemtiere abschießen lassen gegen den
Willen von Naturschützern
[Musik]
die Ukraine hat eine besonders schlimme
Nacht hinter sich einen Nacht des
Terrors sagt der Präsident im ganzen
Land herrschte wegen heftiger russischer
Angriffe Luftalarm nach ukrainischen
Angaben kamen mindestens 20 Menschen ums
Leben zahlreiche würden verletzt
in der Stadt niebro starben eine Mutter
und ihre kleine Tochter erstmals nach
zwei Monaten flogen Raketen auch wieder
Richtung Kiew konnten aber offenbar
weitgehend abgefangen werden die meisten
Todesopfer gab es 250 km südlich von
Kiew in der Stadt Oman
gebrochene Menschen sie stehen vor ihrem
Hochhaus in Oman in dem ihre liebsten
unter Trümmern liegen und wahrscheinlich
tot sind
früh morgens als fast alle schlafen
schlagen die Raketen ein in einer
Wohngegend militärstrategisch offenbar
ohne Bedeutung
überall flogen Glas haben herum ich zog
die Bettdecke über unsere Köpfe und
fragte meinen Mann ob er noch lebt
draußen brannt ist da schon lichterloh
weil jede Sekunde zählt löschen Graben
und Bergen die Helfer alles gleichzeitig
über 100 Menschen sollen im zerstörten
Wohnblock gelebt haben
jeder kannte jeden erzählt ein Nachbar
viele arbeiteten in derselben Fabrik
wohnten seit Jahrzehnten im Haus eine
große Wohngemeinschaft ausgelöscht
eine ältere Frau ihre Tochter und zwar
Enkel lebten im neuen Stock alle tot ein
Mann und sein Sohn im achten Stock auf
Tod eine Mutter mit ihrer Tochter im
siebten Stock ebenfalls tot
auch in der Großstadt niepro endet die
Bomben nach dramatisch eine Frau und ihr
Kind sterben insgesamt fliegen auf sechs
Städte 23 Raketen immerhin 21 davon habe
man abgewehrt meldet Kiew
dieses scheinbar wahllose Bombardement
könnte eine Warnung Russlands an die
Ukraine sein denn dort reden alle von
ihrer bevorstehenden Gegenoffensive auf
die besetzten Gebiete angeblich neu
formierte Brigaden werden beim
angriffstraining gezeigt der bei betont
der Westen Waffen und Munition habe man
zuletzt massiv geliefert und der
ukrainische Verteidigungsminister sagt
Zitat im weitesten Sinne sei man bereit
fragen wir unseren Reporter daran Hassan
du bist in saporicia Dara etwa 40 bis 50
km von der Front entfernt was ist von
der Mobilmachung zu sehen
ja bei unseren Fahrten zu diversen
Frontabschnitten konnten wir schon
deutlich mehr Truppenbewegungen
beobachten als in den Zeiten davor die
Soldaten die wir trafen erzählten uns
auch von Verlegungen von
Truppenkonzentrationen hin und wieder
sagen wir auch punktuell sehr schweres
Gerät auf den Straßen die was für
transportiert wurde mein Team war heute
zugegen bei einer angriffsübung von
verschiedenen Waffengattungen dort wird
werden Angriffe im Verbund trainiert
also es ist sehr viel hier in Bewegung
alles deutet darauf hin dass die
Vorbereitungen im Folgenden Gange sind
wenn ich sogar wirklich abgeschlossen
doch ein konkreten Zeitpunkt wann dieser
diese Offensive beginnen könne der die
kann ich daraus aus dem Beobachtungen
noch nicht ableiten
danke schön
aus saporea
nach Deutschland und zu den Auswirkungen
des russischen angriffskriegs die
Inflation bleibt auf hohem Niveau auch
wenn Sie in diesem Monat leicht gesunken
ist mit Beginn des ukrainekriegs kannte
die Preissteigerung vor allem einen Weg
nach oben und das ganz schnell auf mehr
als 10%. inzwischen geht sie etwas
zurück
7,2% im April Alexander Pool mit den
Einzelheiten
Pauline Abt betreibt ein kleines
käsegeschäft in München schon seit
Monaten spürt sie eine deutliche
Zurückhaltung bei ihren Kunden auch bei
denen die regelmäßig zum Einkaufen
kommen viele Leute kommen rein und
Fragen intensiver nach dem Preisen oder
greifen dann zu dem günstigeren und
gerade Ende des Monats merkt man es auch
deutlich dass die Leute weniger kaufen
also das merkt man am Umsatz einfach
auch auf dem Münchner Wochenmarkt könne
von sinkenden Preisen nicht die Rede
sein sagen die die hier einkaufen
Fleisch ganz teuer also wirklich schon
vor sehr teuer selbst Gemüse muss ich
sagen ist auch teilweise noch sehr teuer
beim Einkaufen merkt man das kostet
nicht mehr 40 Euro sondern 60 Euro da
einkauft ich kaufe jetzt manche Dinge
nicht mehr die ich früher ab und zu
gekauft habe es fühlt sich wie ein
Widerspruch an zwar geht die
Inflationsrate insgesamt seit Monaten
zurück vor allem aufgrund sinkender
Energiepreise Lebensmittel aber
verteuern sich weiter wenn auch weniger
stark im März waren es plus 17 Prozent
Verbraucherschützer vermuten dahinter
auch die Gier großer
Lebensmittelhersteller
Wirtschaftsexperten schließen weitere
Preisanstiege nicht aus und erklären
dies mit einem Nachholeffekt
das liegt eben daran dass zum einen
viele dieser Anbieter von konsumaren
Dienstleistungen und von waren die
gestiegenen Kosten ja auch erst jetzt
bekommen haben und die geben eben diese
kostenanstiege jetzt auch nach unten
nach weiter für viele Menschen heißt das
bei ihrem wöchentlichen Einkauf die
Sonderangebote weiter im Blick behalten
die deutsche Wirtschaft tut sich weiter
schwer in den ersten drei Monaten des
Jahres stagnierte sie auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt blieb dadurch die sonst
übliche Frühjahrsbelebung aus im April
waren laut Bundesagentur für Arbeit zwei
Millionen
586.000 Menschen ohne Job das sind 8.000
weniger als im März die
Arbeitslosenquote liegt unverändert bei
5,7 Prozent im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
sind
276.000 Menschen mehr arbeitslos
das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat Fehler
eingeräumt bei der Auswahl des Chefs der
Deutschen Energieagentur Dehner das
Verfahren werde neu gestartet sagte eine
Sprecherin Hintergrund sind Vorwürfe der
Vetternwirtschaft es war bekannt
geworden dass der Trauzeuge von
Wirtschafts-
der Tag nach der wahlklatsche in Berlin
erst im dritten Anlauf war der
Regierende Bürgermeister Kai Wegner
gestern gewählt worden jetzt muss ich
der neue aus der CDU mit seinem Team
beweisen was nicht ganz einfach ist in
einer schwarz-roten Koalition die von
großen Teilen der SPD gar nicht gewollt
wird aus der Hauptstadt berichtet Stefan
Merseburger bin da melde mich zum Wien
bis gestern noch Regierende
Bürgermeisterin und Nummer eins in der
Stadt seit heute Wirtschaftssenatorin
und Nummer zwei wie weiter nach dem
vielstaat gestern ich bin zuversichtlich
dass mit dem Team was heute vorgestellt
wird was sehr divers ist was aus
unterschiedlichsten erfahrungshorizonten
Menschen zusammenbringt das hat eine
gute Chance dass das auch gut wird
sieben Sinne Turnerinnen kein Senat war
je weiblicher und keiner diverse drei
Senatoren haben Migrationshintergrund
mit dieser Zusammensetzung will kein
Wegner zeigen dass er Metropole kann
seine Wahl
trotzdem zur Blamage bei der Stadt war
holprig dass es doch gar keine Frage und
da gibt es auch gar nichts schön zu
reden ich hätte mir auch gewünscht im
ersten Wahlgang gewählt worden zu sein
aber jetzt was der dritte und jetzt bin
ich im Amt jetzt ist der neue Senat im
Amt der schwarz-rote Senat und wir
wollen das Beste für Berlin und das
gehen wir jetzt an die Verwaltung soll
modernisiert und digitalisiert werden
mehr Tempo beim Wohnungsbau und bis zu 4
Milliarden Euro für den Ankauf von
Wohnungen bis zu 10 Milliarden Euro für
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen mehr Personal und
bessere Ausstattung für Polizei und
Feuerwehr ehrgeizige Vorhaben können die
mit dieser Koalition gelingen kein
Wegner muss jetzt sofort um
Handlungsfähigkeit zu beweisen und
dieses fatale einstiegsmoment vergessen
zu machen er muss sofort die großen
Projekte anpacken wenn das nicht gelingt
dann verliert er weiter ein Autorität
und dann wird der Streit in dieser
Koalition immer weitergehen
das Ende des Streits so lautet das große
antrittsversprechend diese Koalition
der Reisekonzern TUI hat die staatlichen
corona-hilfen vollständig zurückgezahlt
die letzte Tranche über 750 Millionen
Euro hat das Unternehmen nach eigenen
Angaben heute überwiesen die tUI hatte
während der Pandemie rund 4,3 Milliarden
Euro Finanzhilfe vom Staat bekommen
die Bundeswehr ist nach ihrem
evakuierungseinsatz im Sudan nach
Deutschland zurückgekehrt am Nachmittag
landeten mehrere Maschinen der Luftwaffe
auf dem Fliegerhorst Wunstorf
Außenministerin baerbock und
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius nahmen
die Truppe in Empfang beim sogenannten
Rückkehrer abhält danken beide den
Soldaten für ihren gefährlichen Einsatz
mehr als 700 Menschen hatte die
Bundeswehr aus dem umkämpften Sudan in
Sicherheit gebracht
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius hat es
versprochen die Bundeswehr soll künftig
preiswerte einkaufen und schneller
lieber Waffensysteme von der Stange die
schon am Markt verfügbar sind als teure
Neuentwicklungen ausdrücklich
ausgenommen dass europäische
luftkampfsystem F cas das steht für
future combat Air System und soll mal
den Euro Fighter ersetzen dessen
Weiterentwicklung haben Deutschland
Frankreich und Spanien heute besiegelt
Thomas Walde
Europas größtes Rüstungsprojekt
geschätzte kosten 100 Milliarden Euro
FSK soll mehr werden als ein
kampflugzeug ein vernetztes System aus
Flugzeugen Drohnen Cloud technisch und
strategisch ein Hoch fliegendes Projekt
es geht darum ob wir in Zukunft als
Europäer auf der militärischen und
industriellen Weltbühne noch existieren
oder dazu verdammt sind was allen oder
abhängig zu werden
frühestens 2014 soll das System
einsetzbar sein dabei hatte der deutsche
Minister der Bundeswehr gerade mehr
Tempo befohlen kaufen statt bauen ein
Widerspruch das heißt aber nicht und
deswegen ist es kein Widerspruch das
große entwicklungslösung noch dazu
solche die man tunlichst nicht alleine
angehen sollte dass die nicht trotzdem
stattfinden bzw fortgesetzt werden wir
reden über einen Kampfflugzeug der
sechsten Generation was noch geflogen
werden wird wenn ich schon lange nicht
mehr lebe doch schon vor dem ersten
testfluggerät fkas in turbulanzen
deutsche französische spanische Firmen
Ringen um Anteile Fachleute fordern dass
die Politik mehr tut als bisher so ein
Projekt könne auch scheitern
die Politik muss hier deutlich mehr und
stärker steuern also schneller die
technischen Anforderungen bestimmen und
die Anteile der Industrien an der
Entwicklung festlegen
das gilt nicht nur für FKS beim ähnlich
ambitionierten gemeinsamen
panzer-projekt Ringen die
Rüstungsindustrie so heftig das kaum
etwas vorankommt so war das Treffen der
Minister in Madrid bestenfalls ein
Zwischenstopp auf dem Weg zur
europäischen Souveränität
zurück nach Deutschland zu einem
weiteren Puzzleteil der Energiewende der
Geothermie in Anwesenheit des
Bundeskanzlers wurde heute in Schwerin
eine neue Anlage eröffnet das ganze
funktioniert so tief in der Erde ist es
ja heiß genug um an diese Wärme zu
gelangen braucht es aber bis zu 6 km
tiefe Bohrungen Wasser zum Heizen wird
dann dort in 200 Grad heißen
Gesteinsschichten erwärmt
woanders findet sich direkt warmes
Thermalwasser zum anzapfen
abgekühltes Wasser gelangt dann wieder
nach unten ein Kreislauf entsteht
geothermisch besonders interessant sind
das Alpenvorland der Oberrhein und
Norddeutschland und von dort aus
Schwerin berichtet Susanne Seidel
diesen Termin lässt sich der Kanzler in
Zeiten der Energiewende nicht nehmen die
Einweihung der Geothermieanlage in
Schwerin aus 1.300 Metern wird hier
heißes Wasser aus der Tiefe gepumpt die
daraus gewonnene Wärme soll künftig 15%
des fernwärmebedarfs der Stadt decken
und deshalb machen uns Projekte wie
dieses hier nicht nur unabhängiger von
den volatilen Gaspreisen von der
geopolitischen Großlage und von
Marktschwankungen bei der fossilen
Energie sie können die Grundlast auch an
sonnen und windaben Tagen sichern im
Moment liegt der Anteil der Geothermie
beim wärmemix in Deutschland bei nur
knapp über ein Prozent experten sehen
zukünftig ein weitaus größeres Potenzial
das ist möglich bis 2045 zu 100%
klimaneutral zu sein auch in der
Wärmeversorgung die Geothermie spielt
dabei die zentrale Rolle die Risiken bei
den Tiefbohrungen sind nach ihrer
Einschätzung inzwischen beherrschbar die
Gefahr etwa von Erdbeben gering in
Neustadt-Glewe hat die wärmewende schon
vor Jahrzehnten begonnen die
Geothermieanlage versorgt mehr als 600
Haushalte über das Fernwärmenetz wir
können uns vor Anfragen nicht retten
derzeit müssen leider natürlich sagen da
wo wir das Netz noch nicht ausgebaut
haben da müssen wir entschuldigen und
sagen okay vielleicht in den nächsten
fünf Jahren können wir sie ran nehmen es
braucht ein gut ausgebautes
Fernwärmenetz um ganze Stadtteile mit
Geothermie zu versorgen also viel Geld
für Investitionen
kleine Entschuldigung offenbar haben
einige Tonprobleme das möchten wir
bitten zu entschuldigen wir wissen noch
nicht genau woran es liegt aber werden
dem auf dem Grund gehen vor drei Wochen
hatte der Tod einer zehnjährigen in
einem Kinderheim in Oberfranken Aufsehen
erregt ein elfjähriger aus dem Heim in
Wunsiedel stand unter Verdacht an der
Tat beteiligt zu sein jetzt gibt es über
eine überraschende Wende die Polizei
geht nun doch von einem Sexualverbrechen
aus ein 25-jähriger sitzt in
Untersuchungshaft Jutta sonnewald hat
mehr
in dieser Kinder- und Jugendeinrichtung
im oberfränkischen Wunsiedel wurde
Anfang April die Leiche eines
Zehnjährigen Mädchens gefunden nun gibt
es nach mehreren Wochen eine
überraschende Wende ein 25-Jähriger aus
dem Landkreis Wunsiedel wurde
festgenommen die Ermittler gehen von
einem Sexualverbrechen aus der
Tatverdacht gegen diesen hat sich
dadurch ergeben dass eine Vielzahl von
Spuren ausgewertet wurde hierzu zählen
insbesondere molekular genetische sprich
dNA Spuren darüber hinaus wurden
dackeloskopische Spuren insbesondere im
Fingerabdrücke gesichert und auch gab es
digitale Spuren die rechtsmedizinische
Untersuchung des Leichnams hat ergeben
dass das Mädchen durch Gewalteinwirkung
am Hals gestorben ist welche Rolle der
Verdächtige elfjährige spielt der
ebenfalls im Heim untergebracht war ist
noch unklar der Junge wurde inzwischen
gemeinsam mit Psychologen vernommen doch
er hat sich bisher nicht zur Tat
geäußert momentan ist es so dass der
25-Jährige in Untersuchungshaft sitzt
der elfjährige ist weiter hin verdächtig
an der Tat beteiligt gewesen zu sein und
die weiteren Ermittlungen müssen die
Zusammenhänge jetzt erst zeigen
besonders auch die Motivlage oder vor
Beziehungen bestehen auch wie und wo die
Tat geschehen ist ist noch unklar die
für diesen Fall eingesetzte 40 köpfige
Sonderkommission Park ermittelt weiter
heißt diskutiert wird hierzulande immer
wieder über Wölfe darf man Problem Wölfe
unbürokratisch und möglichst schnell
abschießen dass jedenfalls fordert der
Bauernverband heute auf einem
sogenannten wolfsgipfel seit der
Rückkehr der Raubtiere in Deutschland
hat ihre Zahl stetig zugenommen vor
allem im Nordosten des Landes Jan Meyer
hat Details sie sorgen sich um ihre
Weidetiere Bauern demonstrieren am
Vormittag mitten in Berlin fordern einen
strengeren Umgang mit dem Wolf er muss
dezimiert werden fertig aus Ende und
gerade die die Übergriffe die müssen
sofort weg ja und wir brauchen den
teichschutz und brauchen die Schafe und
wenn der Wolf kommt und die Schafe reißt
dann haben wir ein Problem
europaweit steht der Wolf seit über vier
Jahrzehnten unter streng im Schutz mit
Erfolg in Deutschland wird der Bestand
auf etwa 2000 Tiere geschätzt
der Wolf gehört hier bei uns in das
Ökosystem er ist einer der Beutegreifer
die wir haben neben dem Luchs und neben
vielen kleinen Beutegreifern wieder
Wildkatze und natürlich ist es beim Wolf
die Herausforderung eben genau diese
Frage des herdenschutzes in Griff zu
kriegen wir müssen wieder lernen mit dem
Wolf zusammen zu leben doch auch die
Zahl der tödlichen Angriffe auf
Nutztiere stieg an seit 2015 hat sie
sich mehr als vervierfacht auf beinahe
4000 auf dem wolfsgipfel des Deutschen
Bauernverbandes in Berlin zeitgleich zur
Demo sprachen sich Landwirte einhellig
dafür aus künftig öfter Wölfe Schießen
zu dürfen
wir müssen mal festlegen die
populationshöhe die verträglich ist in
unseren Region auch in den
unterschiedlichen Regionen und wenn die
Population darüber hinaus steigt muss
systematisch der Wolf bejagt werden der
Wolf hat in den vergangenen Jahren
seinen Platz in der Natur in Deutschland
zurückerobert leidtragende sind aber
viele Weide Bauern und ihre Tiere der
Konflikt bleibt ungelöst
jetzt zu Fußball Bundesliga
am Sonntag zu haben daheim gegen den
Tabellen letzten Hertha aber was ist in
diesen Tagen schon einfach beim
kriselnden FCB
nach zehn Jahren deutscher
dauermeisterschaft können die Bayern den
Titel fünf spieltage-verschluss aus
eigener Kraft allein schon nicht mehr
holen das eins zu drei in Mainz am
letzten Samstag hat auch die letzte
Münchner Titelchance mit Trainer Tuchel
ins Wanken gebracht
wir haben es nicht mehr selber in der
Hand und und das Ziel muss jetzt sein 15
Punkte zu holen und wenn wir so ganz
klar kommuniziert wenn das so weiter
spielen so schwankend und
wie wie war die letzten beiden
Bundesligaspiele gespielt haben wird uns
das nicht gelingen den misser Erfolg
müsste dann auch Bayern Vorstand Oliver
Kahn verantworten es wäre das erste
titellose Bayern Jahr seit 2012
Deutscher Meister damals Borussia
Dortmund
zur Fußball Champions League der Frauen
gestern Abend in Barcelona das
Halbfinale Rückspiel gegen Chelsea vor
über 72.000 Fans im legendären Kanu
Barca erreichte das eins zu eins zu dem
Finale Einzug und trifft dort auf
Arsenal oder Wolfsburg
Barcelona feiert in einer unglaublichen
Kulisse den dritten Finaleinzug
nacheinander was das Frauen das
überliegende Team Caroline Graham Hansen
mit der Führung in der 63 Minute wieder
lief alles bei der Ex Wolfsburgerin
zusammen bereits im Hinspiel hatte
Graham Hansen getroffen vier Minuten
später der erste gefährliche Angriff der
Blues die Norwegerin Guru Reiten mit dem
Ausgleich mehr gelang Chelsea allerdings
nicht Wasser im Finale am 3 juni ob
Wolfsburg Wolken kann entscheidet sich
Montag
schwere Niederlage und schwere
Verletzung die deutschen Handballer
haben auch ihr fünftes eurocup-spiel
verloren 23 zu 32 gegen Europameister
Schweden ja und dazu auch noch ihren
Stammspieler Paul Drucks der Berliner
Rückraum routiniert zog sich ohne Fremd
Einwirkung einen Achillessehnenriss zu
und fällt für fünf acht für viele Monate
aus
der Unterschied jetzt auch dem Berliner
Füchsen im Kampf um die deutsche
handballmeister gute Besserung und jetzt
noch eine schöpferische Reise vom hellen
ins Dunkle mitten in der Nacht in der
Karlsruhe U-Bahn hat der Künstler Markus
Lüpertz sein Projekt Genesis enthüllt
seine persönliche Interpretation der
Schöpfungsgeschichte dort wo sonst
Reklame Tafeln hängen schmücken nun 14
keramikreliefs die Bahnhöfe zehn Jahre
hat der 82-Jährige daran gearbeitet
hellfreundlich und trocken das sind die
Wetteraussichten für dieses lange
Wochenende die Details hat gleich
Christa Orben das heute journal um 10
mit Christian Sievers das gesamte heute
Team sagt Danke und wünscht Ihnen ein
schönes Wochenende bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
ja guten Abend der April 2023 war der
nasseste april in Deutschland seit 15
Jahren und das hat zur Folge dass ich
auch die Bodenfeuchte wieder vollständig
erholt hat und auch heute Nacht ist es
ja noch sehr nass der Regen verlagert
sich dann ostwärts aber die kräftigen
Gewitter im Südwesten und der Dauerregen
an den Alpen lassen im Verlauf dann
langsam nach da wo es auf Platt kann
sich auch mal Nebel bilden dazu ist die
Nacht im Nordosten nicht mehr so kühl
wie die vergangene hier haben wir sechs
Grad im Süden zehn elf Grad morgen gibt
es vor allem über der Mitte viele Wolken
aus denen hier und da mal auch ein
bisschen Regen fällt inklusive Schauer
an den Alpen sonst wechseln sich Sonne
und Wolken ab viel Sonne gibt es im
Süden und im Norden vor allem an der
Nordsee sind das bis zu 12 Stunden Sonne
im Süden immerhin fünf bis acht Stunden
dazwischen sieht das allerdings drüber
aus mit 0 bis 2 Stunden Sonne die
Temperaturen sind sehr unterschiedlich
11 Grad an der Nordsee südlich der Donau
und am Oberrhein 20-21 Grad und das ist
auch die Temperaturspanne der nächsten
Tage am Sonntag gibt's dazu trockenes
Ausflugswetter der Montag wird im Süden
allerdings ein bisschen unbeständiger da
kannst nachmittags dann auch kräftige
Gewitter geben im nordostenschein
allerdings die Sonne am ersten Mai der
Dienstag wird noch mal etwas
wechselhafter aber insgesamt das ein
ganz trockenes Wochenende tschüss